ils sont ils ces convoyeurs de la
liberté on va justement leur poser la
question on va leur donner la parole on
est en direct tout de suite avec régine
briquet aux retraités qui participent à
ce qu'on voit bonsoir madame merci nous
apportez votre témoignage ce soir
pourquoi avoir rejoint le le mouvement
parce que nous avons été traités de sous
citoyens par monsieur makoura lui
montrer qu'on n'est pas des 6 août sous
citoyens je voudrais déjà faire un
rectificatif et vous lire
le comité officière de convois france ce
sont les raisons pour lesquelles nous
allons nous mettre à la mairie de paris
ensuite ceux qui le souhaitent pourront
aller dans paris pour rejoindre les
manifestations qu'il souhaite puisque
rats plusieurs manifestations
le communiqué officiel
elle n'y en a pas d'autre et les
citoyens entendent récupérer leur
liberté leurs droits fondamentaux
l'accès inconditionnel aux soins à
l'éducation à la culture
le respect des valeurs essentielles de
notre constitution
sovo inscrit 6 des enfants et de la
jeunesse se sont à maltraitances subies
quotidiennement vous voyez bien que
derrière ces revendications nous ne
parlons absolument pas des
revendications ont présenté les gilets
jaunes
rémy que notre responsable nicolas que
j'ai vu en vidéo ya pas longtemps avec
maria et marisa il sait très bien que ce
mouvement est totalement pacifique et
apolitique
alors c'est vrai qu'un homme politique
qui à côté un haut responsable
il a dit on vous attend philippon a dit
on vise à temps et
un autre responsable a répondu non c'est
vous qui nous rejoignent et de façon
neutre il n'y a aucune tendance
politique dans ce couloir
répondre aux deux messages pas de
tendance politique mais ce qui est
intéressant parce qu'aujourd'hui voilà
on s'est beaucoup posé la question ici
ou là de savoir si ce mouvement était un
nouveau mouvement des gilet jaune vous
dites maintenant nous ce sont nos
revendications ce que vous venez de nous
lire le communiqué sauf que sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien il ya des
anciens gilet jaune qui se sont greffés
on va d'ailleurs certainement les
entendre on les a déjà entendus
notamment sur les questions du pouvoir
d'achat ça vous n'êtes pas vraiment
d'accord ou ou tout simplement c'est un
mouvement qui semble peut-être échappé
aux organisateurs et qui prend de
l'ampleur avec d'autres revendications
d'autres mécontentements
non c'est une confusion qui vient dans
les esprits parce qu'il est vrai que
l'usiné zone se sont beaucoup battus
mais le but ce n'est pas les
revendications du gilet jaune même si
elles sont justifiées mais normalement
il n'ya aucune revendication et c'est
vrai que sur les réseaux il y à une
confusion c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu à
vous lier le communiqué officiel chaque
personne va à cette manifestation va
dire que ce chaque personne
indépendante qui retrouve un ensemble de
personnes on parle pas politique du tout
mais nous ce sont politisées pardonnez
moi mais c'était tout simplement départ
des simples citoyens français qui
parlait pouvoir d'achat ça veut dire que
ça a été dévoyé selon vous et qu'ils se
sont un peu politisée vous réfutez leur
présence aujourd'hui
non je réfute pas du tout leur présence
on est très contents qu'il soit là
évidemment c'est il faut savoir que les
médias il faut au moins je regarde tous
les médias et je passe mon temps à
calmer a rectifié sur les réseaux menthe
absolument / 7 / ont menti sur les
gilets jaunes pour les discréditer et
comme ils essayent de discréditer et il
déjà il annonce déjà des manifestations
mais je crois qu'à paris ils s'attendent
pas cet événement
pacifique
d'un événement pacifique et non
politisée on va pas pouvoir empêcher les
banderoles on va pas pouvoir empêcher
des gens avec des revendications sur le
sur le pouvoir d'achat ce n'est pas
l'objectif principal
de cette manifestation
pacifique qui de demandes que le retour
aux libertés merci en tout cas régime
briquettes de londres avoir apporter
votre témoignage